في دوله لا دستور فيها المحكمه العليا في
اسرائيل وجهه السياسيين والمشرعين
للاحتكام اليها تؤدي دورا ناظما بين
السلطات وهكذا فان التغييرات التي يدعمها
تيار اقصى اليمين تثير مخاوف من تداعياتها
فالمحكمه العليا تشكل جوهر الخلاف في
التغييرات حيث تؤدي دورا في حفظ التوازن
السياسي مع غياب اي دستور لاسرائيل
تنظر المحكمه العليا في القضايا كافه ضد
السلطات الدوله ودستوريه القوانين لذلك
فان احد الاهداف الاساسيه للتغيير القضائي
هو تمكين الحكومه من التحكم في اصدار
القوانين وتمرير التشريعات سواء التي
ابطلتها المحكمه في السابق او التي سوف
تمرر مستقبلا بموافقه اغلبيه بسيطه من
اعضاء الكنيست تشمل خطه التغييرات
القضائيه منحى اعضاء الكنيست نفوذا اوسع
في لجنه تعيين قضاه المحكمه العليا بزياده
عدد اعضاء اللجنه وسط مخاوف من ان يعلو
صوت السياسيين منهم على صوت التكنوقرات او
اهل الاختصاص ويراد من التغييرات ايضا
حمايه بنيامين نتنياهو وحلفائه لاسيما حزب
شاس وزعيمه اريا درعي في مشكلاتهم
القانونيه
وقضايا الفساد والاحتيال بسن قوانين تمنع
تنحيه رئيس الوزراء من منصبه
وهناك طريقتان لفعل ذلك
تنحي رئيس الوزراء بنفسه بابلاغ الكنيست
او تنحيه الحكومه باغلبيه ثلاثه ارباع
وزرائها وتاييد الكنيست باغلبيه 90 عضوا
[موسيقى]